j'accueille maintenant et verrerie
gobain elsa zylberstein
andy garcia et hippolyte girardot
[Applaudissements]
voilà
garcia bonsoir bonsoir et oui bonsoir
hippolyte
rassurez moi vous avez un lien de
parenté avec josé garcia regrette ou
legacy a fait partie de la même famille
d'accueil sergent yves alsace agent très
étroitement liés même bien alors vous
vous étiez ici à ya quinze jours pour le
film de laetitia masson et ce soir vous
êtes tous réunis nous vous en remercions
pour le film maudit litanie de mick
davis qui sort en salles le 29 septembre
donc avec vous tous plus eu de cris
rires et omid djalili voilà voilà le
casting alors je fais le pitch ce sont
les derniers mois de la vie du peintre
modigliani et il son histoire d'amour
avec jeanne hébuterne sur fond de
rivalité avec picasso dont vous jouez
olga l'accompagnent ma chère eva
herzigova et puis c'est aussi le paris
de l'après première guerre mondiale
le pari des artistes qui passent de
montparnasse à montmartre voilà alors
l'époque picasso et déjà auréolé par le
par le succès modigliani et pauvres
consumé par l'alcool par une maladie
pulmonaire par la drogue
et puis son histoire avec jeanne
effectivement c'est l'une des plus
belles histoires d'amour de la peinture
en fait c'est une histoire qui ressemble
aussi on pourrait dire à celles de
camille claudel et de rodin dans ce sens
où elle était peintre et puis cette
histoire d'amour et passionnel au point
que jeanne qui qui peut pas vivre sans
cet homme-là un moment donné il
déclinait il se détruit lui même et elle
va jusqu'à mourir à la fin elle meurt en
fait le lendemain de modigliani suicide
le lendemain de sa mort est le père de
jeanne qui aiment pas modigliani parce
qu'il est juif préfère confier l'enfant
qu'ils ont eu ensemble aux bonnes soeurs
volantes c'est une histoire très très
tragique
on va voir à quoi ça ressemble d'abord
alors vous allez dire andy garcia s'il
vous plaît clayeux look at you came la
de one with the red light and a new jazz
c'est magnéto ch3 light
il va lui dire serge tu l'auras magnéto
serge par andy garcia tu l'auras manette
c'est ouais
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs je vous présente
picasso
il y avait un génie qu'on admirait
un artiste ou se casse le grand
modigliani
on adorerait c'est comme ça que vous
voyez comment appeler mois maudit
maintenant c'est à mon tour de mon père
chance je pense à vos yeux
[Applaudissements]
l église ni est à deux doigts de vendre
météo modigliani
[Musique]
avec fougue
on ne peut pas changer le destin
quel destin lucien son amour pour lui
dis moi pas bhl comment fait on laboure
un cul tu sais bien que le tout paris
attend avec impatience le jour où toi et
picasso serait en compétition rentrer
dans l'arène tique un peu le minotaure à
levi fin
quoi mais tu as toi m'a dit je t'aime
pablo c'est moi que je déteste
1 et garcia me dit mon ami
pas autant souffrir pour ton art
tout ce qu'on demande c'est par elsa
zylberstein
modigliani
avec andy garcia gilbert sigma hippolyte
girardot
ils sont nos invités ce soir alors vous
avez accepté de jouer ce film modigliani
parce qu avait pas de scènes de nu et de
scènes de sexe et vous dites quand j'ai
lu le scénario j'ai arraché toutes les
pages où il y avait des scènes au lit
avec elsa ou avec et 20 j'essaie
d'écrire à te garde les scènes où eva
elsa seraient ensemble up
pourquoi vous vous refusez de jouer des
scènes de sexe au cinéma sérieusement et
disons que j'ai de petits détails sinon
[Applaudissements]
nous allons y est on est en france
oui j'aimerais beaucoup vous savez qu'en
france on se lave une fois par semaine
vous savez ça oui malheureusement je ne
servais
[Musique]
alors andy garcia vous êtes né à cuba
dans une famille très très aisée votre
père était avocat était aussi
propriétaire terrien et jusqu'en 1959
jusqu'à l'arrivée à la havane d'un autre
avocat nommé fidel castro tout va bien
et après 1961 après l'histoire de la
baie des cochons et la crise des
missiles à cuba devient un état marxiste
léniniste les terres sont nationalisées
et votre père décide de partir aux états
unis à miami avec sa femme et ses trois
enfants
à l'époque vous avez 5 ans et une partie
importante c'est que nous n'avons pas
quitté cuba parce que l'éternité saisis
parce qu'on nous prenait également notre
liberté
alors votre père était ouvrier à
l'époque il a été obligé de de
travailler 12 heures par jour six jours
par semaine jusqu'à ce qu'ils fassent
fortune dans les parfums mais il ya eu
une période très dure à ce moment là
n'en des eaux que c'était difficile mais
l'essentiel c'est que nous avions nos
libertés de droit des droits civiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes venus aux états unis des végétaux
de rancoeur ni de tristesse et de la
pauvreté quand même c'est vrai qu'à un
moment vous ramassiers les bouteilles
consignées sur la plage pour aller les
revendre oui on ramenait effectivement
les bouteilles consignées ont récupéré
des sous avec ça et avec ça on
s'achetait un coca ou burqa alors
pendant votre dernière année de lycée
vous êtes malade vous avez une hépatite
vous avez une mononucléose
vous êtes obligé de renoncer au basket
et c'est comme ça que vous commencez à
songer à devenir à devenir acteur vous
en savez plus sur ma vie que moi ben oui
mais c'est vrai ce que vous dites c'est
un épisode de ma vie et c'est comme ça
que j'en suis venu au cinéma
alors là vous faites un petit film en
espagnol à miami et vous décidez
de partir à los angeles où vous
attendrez ces temps avant de faire un
deuxième film c'est vrai vous avez fait
quoi pendant sept ans un peu tout ou un
peu de tout j'étais déménageurs oui
j'arrive entier garçons de café c'est
vrai qu'un jour vous rentrez dans le
bureau d'une femme agent elle est au
téléphone elle vous demande cinq minutes
voulu proposer de sortir vous elle vous
dit de rester
et après elle vous demande d'enlever
votre chemise parce qu'elle vous dit
qu'elle cherchait d un acteur musclé et
vous refusé d'enlever votre chemise je
lui ai dit enlève d'un portage milan
vérone je verrai la mienne vous êtes
très stricte dans tous les cas
concernant les rôles que vous acceptez
ou vous refusez je disais tout à l'heure
que vous refusiez les rôles où il y
avait trop de scènes de nu de scènes de
sexe
vous refusez aussi tous les rôles où
vous êtes un voyou l'hispanique un
dealer de cocaïne
vous êtes très rigoureux là dessus je
choisis les rôles je crois que n'importe
quel acteur va choisir des rôles qui lui
correspondrait mieux auquel on peut
réagir dans la sphère affective je fais
comme tout le monde cependant à ça vous
a pas empêché de faire une carrière
extraordinaire
oui
alors vous dites au delà de ça je suis
un exilé pour le restant de mes jours et
après 12 ans d'acharnement
vous avez réussi à monter un film qui
s'appelle the lost city qui est
l'histoire d'un jeune homme qui doit
quitter sa sa terre à cause d'une d'une
révolution ça a été difficile à monter
ce film en oui et là effectivement
c'était un projet très difficile surtout
à financer ne triche jamais retourné à
cuba réfugiés ceux qui essaient de
s'enfuir à tous ses occupants y avait
quelques 16 mille réfugiés au quai s'est
enfui c'est la seule fois où j'y suis
retourné à la havane jamais non non non
jamais vous attendez que castro meurt
quand il partira je n'agirais alors dont
modigliani vous interprétez olga donc là
la compagne de de picasso qui elle aussi
vient vient de l'est
exact les russes c'était plus facile
c'était ça m'a aidé ça m'a aidé parce
qu'à une chose une sorte de rigueur il
ya une sorte de fierté de l'origine le
mot femme autant mariage un cert
valeur donc ça m'a beaucoup aidé sa
maman ça m'a aidé d'un tap rethel
rodolphe vous avez le caractère cela
vous casser tout parfois ça m'arrive
ouais ouais ouais ouais comme en dit
vous êtes contre les scènes de sexe dans
les films à votre nom ben je crois que
vous avez refusé eyes wide shut de
kubrick non oui je refusais les filles
parce que
pour moins de
accepter faire actrice c'est tellement
similaire au métier de mannequin que je
veux pas que ça risque de faire la même
chose donc je si j'accepte une rolls
pour faire quelque chose différent ouest
et kubrick quand même c'était couvre icm
et je lui a parlé j'ai décidé l'ex de de
s'exprimer il a dit non non je veux que
tu sois nue donc pour moi il voulait
quelque chose qui attire l'attention
sont intenses que je dis donc ça
m'intéressait pas vous avez accepté
malgré tout jouer les anges gardiens
avec les son clavier pour regrettez pas
d'avoir accepté christian clavier est
refusée stanley cup vous vous rappelez
bien c'était bien avant
je suis désolé mais pourquoi vous
refusez kubrick et vous acceptez de
faire des photos nue dans playboy
oh ça aux ap quand on voit tous en plus
j'ai aussi merci beaucoup
pourquoi alors finalement j'ai fait ce
que je voulais ah ils m'ont proposé de
faire les photos à chaque année des
filles et pire les débuts donc
finalement j'ai pas choisir un
photographe comme un mario sorrenti avec
toi il faut insister quoi ouais enfin ne
pas assister mais pour moi c'était
plutôt l'image de l'année dit et ce
n'était pas les photos
chips étaient pas les photos de guerre
si vous allez vous les aimez mais revue
semana qu on disait je les ai plus
d'aisé chez moi une et c'est toujours la
grande elles sont dans mon bureau
punaisé vous êtes contents de vous
savoir ce que l'armée est avec andy
garcia c'est formidable non elle vient
tous les quinze jours elle n'a pu ni à
lui ni à 15 jours et je lui dis qu'on
vous recevez cette semaine elle m'a dit
est ce que je peux revenir avec en
ouverture ce qui m'avait rien vie tabac
et je suis très heureuse non c'est chaud
c'est un très très beau film et c'était
un bonheur de travailler avec andy donc
forcément c'est quelque chose de rare et
c'est un homme vraiment généreux c'est
un acteur extrêmement attentif est venu
habillé
et
six mois
[Applaudissements]
et
ce sont les bas ocho on dit des belles
gambettes
alors vous vous êtes utrillo hippolyte
dans le film a quand vous avez été
embarqués dans cette affaire j'ai été
embarqué un peu par hasard comme ça au
dernier moment
ouais mick davis m'a proposé le rôle on
a parlé en fait de londres des années 60
et je lui ai dit en fait oui tous ses
potes qui se voyait ensemble qui
buvaient ensemble qui peignait quand
même pourquoi ensemble qui se d'état de
trucs ensemble c'est un peu il ya des il
ya des moments comme ça historique dans
certaines villes où ça se passe comme
londres en 64 c'est vrai et paris en
usage en mer
ouais c'est ça et perd août juste avant
la guerre en 72 points 13 beyrouth était
la seule ville arabe au monde on pouvait
publier ce qu'on voulait par exemple ça
c'est des moments très particuliers et
c'est vrai que j'ai parlé de ça il m'a
rappelée au téléphone me souviens il m'a
dit tu youyou craig campbell
andy garcia comme vous êtes une star
d'hollywood a offert une interview au
hollywood cliché est est ce que vous
avez déjà joué dans une scène où vous
êtes seulement éclairée par la lumière
du réfrigérateur ouvert sur la smart
work
est-ce que vous avez déjà joué dans une
scène vous frapper le sol de votre point
en maudissant celui qui a fait ça est ce
que vous avez déjà joué dans une scène
où vous détestez une fille que vous
aller embrasser dix minutes plus tard
est-ce que vous avez déjà joué dans une
scène vous mettez le doigt sur la bouche
d'une jeune fille pour lui faire chute
avant de l'embrasser dans le film tout
cas est-ce que vous avez déjà joué dans
une scène où faisait l'amour avec une
fille sans que les draps descende plus
bas que les épaules n'a en tout cas pas
consciemment way est ce que j'ai déjà
joué dans une scène vous hésitez entre
le fil jaune et le fil bleu pour
empêcher la bombe de sauter et en mange
impossible de le faire
est-ce que vous avez déjà joué dans une
scène où vous fait engueuler par votre
supérieur noir j'espère que oui
est-ce que vous avez déjà joué dans une
scène vous embrasser fougueusement une
jeune fille sans jamais lui mettre la
main sur les seins deux fois vous avez
déjà joué dans une scène vous tirer plus
de 250 fois sans recharger votre
revolver
avec en ouverture vers dubaï zazie
yannick jadot
une eau qui
jamais jamais
merci à tous les quatre alors c'était la
soirée de gala ce soir j'étais bien
ouais c'est vraiment bien de saper les
filles parce qu'il tape un poids non toi
tu es comme des membres
lui aussi il assure encore une question
look un bond à merci à tous a à bientôt
en dés
les corps est sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu